[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
مرحبًا دكتور جيم ، كيف
حالك ، الشبكة ضعيفة جدًا
ربما تصل اليوم أو غدًا ،
وآمل أيضًا
ربما لست متأكدًا ولكن
جوناس ولد في إريتريا في عام 1991 مثل
معظم سكان إريتريا الذين قابلتهم في  ليبيا هربت
من الدكتاتورية في بلاده
والخدمة العسكرية الإجبارية التي
وصفتها الأمم المتحدة بأنها أقرب إلى العبودية التي
قابلته في عام 2019 في
مركز الاحتجاز الإقليمي في الجبال
جنوب طرابلس ، كنت مع حدود سانسا
التي كانت قد بدأت للتو في تقديم
الاستشارات الطبية  في المركز ، قمت بتبادل
أرقام الهواتف مع العديد من المحتجزين ، حيث إن
المهاجرين الذين يمتلكون هاتفًا ذكيًا هو الطريقة الوحيدة
التي يمكنهم من خلالها الحفاظ على الاتصال مع
عائلاتهم ولكن أيضًا مع الأشخاص الذين
يتصلون بمساعديهم ونشطاء
وصحفيين يبذلون ما في وسعهم
لمساعدتهم أو للحصول على  المعلومات
بعد وقت قصير من لقائي مع جوناس ، بدأنا في
إرسال رسائل نصية لبعضنا البعض ،
غادرت ليبيا لكنني بقيت على اتصال هاتفي
مع جوناس ودايتون الآخرين
الذين لديهم sma  تنشر الهواتف المحمولة
مقاطع فيديو على وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي للاحتجاجات التي
أقاموها داخل السجن ، حيث يستخدمون
صلصة الطماطم والفلفل الأحمر لكتابة شعارات
على مراتبهم
[موسيقى]
أخبرني بعض الأشخاص الآخرين أن حوالي
30 شخصًا قد نجوا من جوناس ، أحدهم بعد
خمسة أشهر  لقد عدت إلى ليبيا
وتمكنت من إعادة الاتصال به
[تصفيق]
بينما ينتظر القارب ليكون جاهزًا
والبحر ليكون هادئًا ، جوناس قلق
بشأن موقع سفن الإنقاذ ،
يرجى إرسال رسالة نصية لي إذا  لديك أي
معلومات عميقة أو أي معلومات حول
ذلك ،
فقط أرسل لي رسالة
هناك وأخبره أن المحيط فايكنغ السفينة
المستأجرة من قبل sos mediterranean و
mexico Frontier محظورة في فرنسا
وإيطاليا ومالطا تستخدم
الوباء المطلوب لعرقلة عمليات الإنقاذ
ولكن سفينة إنقاذ أخرى  ألين
كردي في طريقه إلى ليبيا ،
مرحباً ، كيف
حالك أنت بخير ،
ماذا عنك ،
آمل أن تكون على دراية
بالفيروس
مهتمة جدًا في هذا الوقت
لأنني أغني موسيقى الراب ،
أنا في انتظار  طعنات طويلة
هنا وهذا هو السبب في أنني لن
أهتم بفكرة هذا
الفيديو ،
وآمل أن تكون
هذه هي المرة الأخيرة بالنسبة لنا
إذا وصلنا مرة واحدة ، فهذا يعني
بعد بضعة أسابيع توقف جوناس عن الرد
على
هاتفه ، يجب أن يكون ذلك لأنه في  البحر ،
مرحبا مرحبا دكتور جيروم كيف حالك
أنا جوناس أنا صادق معك نحن في
استفتاء فيكتوريا آه نعم ثلاثة
أيام نحن في مياه مالطا
عادوا إلى
المياه التونسية لأننا انتهينا من
البنزين الذي نحن فيه  مشكلة كبيرة هناك الآن
نحن في تونس الداخلية كما هو الحال
في تونس بعض الأسماك
التي يحضرونها لنا إلى تونس لذلك نحن في
كرنتانا كورانتانا في تونس الآن
نحتاج إلى مساعدة
[موسيقى]
جوناس مرهق يقول إنه غادر ليبيا
منذ ثلاثة أيام في الساعة الرابعة في  في الصباح كان هناك
خمسون شخصًا على متن 40 إريتريًا
بما في ذلك طفل رضيع اثنان نيجيريان
وسنغاليون واحد وغاني وخمسة
باكستانيون ، قام قارب الصيد بجرهم
على بعد ستة أميال من الساحل التونسي
واختفوا شمالًا
وتمكنوا من إيصال أنفسهم إلى
قبل أن يتم القبض على خفر السواحل التونسي من قبل خفر السواحل التونسي
، ليس من المستحيل أن تتوقف السلطات المالطية
عن الرد مرة أخرى ،
وأنا أيضًا على اتصال
بإسحاق إريتريا آخر هرب من
مركز الاحتجاز المؤهل ، وسألته عما إذا كان لديه
أي  أخبار من جوناس ،
باستخدام المعلومات التي أعطاني إياها إسحاق ،
اتصلت بهاتف الإنذار ، وهو خط ساخن
يضغط على
مراكز الإنقاذ المالطية والإيطالية لبدء عمليات الإنقاذ.
مكالمات
[موسيقى]
مرحبًا جيروم ، كيف حالك أه ، أنا سعيد ،
أنا سعيد للغاية ، أشكرك كثيرًا
لأننا في الحجر الصحي الآن ولا يحتاج أحد
لزيارتنا أو الاتصال بنا لأنه
[موسيقى]
يفعل
[موسيقى
]  أنت